dude literally stalked a woman for
acting research Jamie Dornan was method
acting his crime drama series The Fall
where he plays a serial killer he isn't
relatively normal person inside of the
murders so he could better understand
the mind of such a person he purposely
stalked a woman he saw on the London
Underground he was on the train with her
and she ended up getting off a few stops
before he was planning so he got off
with her and followed her around while
she walked the streets he said though he
wasn't proud of his actions he said he
felt dirty that he did learn something
valuable when it came to playing the
character